(air whooshing)
- You know how fucking lucky,
you're so fucking lucky.
Most people that are watching right now
have to do it for a boss they don't know.
The greatest thing that ever happened
to me is the memories of
being in the fucking trenches
with my dad, you know?
You know, it's crazy that I
get to have those memories.
One day my dad's gonna be
gone and I'm gonna be so happy
about those hours I put
in, those war stories.
You understand?
(slow bass music)
You got your perspective.
(midtempo electronic music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(mellow instrumental music)
- So my question is basically,
I've grown up with some great,
just to give you context, great parents.
Immigrants from Mexico
and they became citizens,
my dad when he was like 20,
and my mom when she was younger.
And, basically, they raised
me and my sister really well.
But, I felt like from my dad's side,
he did a great job of structuring stuff
and making sure I have a good work ethic
and stuff like that.
But, from my mom's side, I felt very like
if life had to be a lot
of fun all the time.
And that created, yeah can you hear?
I can't really hear you.
- I can hear you, I can
hear you, I'm listening.
It's very interesting.
From your my mom's side he put an emphasis
that life has to be fun?
- My mom did, yeah.
She put a big emphasis
that life had to like,
basically, that every
moment I couldn't be sad
and that stuff had to be fun.
And we never really
complained in the house,
or anything like that.
- Interesting.
- But, what's happened is.
And I've gotta kind of now discuss,
I started watching your
content a couple months ago,
but basically,
I got to a point where my
dad took away my allowance.
And I felt like I deserved it.
- Okay.
- Yeah, you know what I mean?
You getting it?
- Yep.
- And I was like.
- When did this happen?
- This happened maybe a
year and a half ago, maybe.
- How old are you?
- If not a year ago, I'm 18.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- Right now, yeah, and basically,
it got me feeling weird now.
I was like, well, you know,
I'm just gonna have to figure
stuff out now, it's whatever.
And my allowance wasn't
that big or anything,
but it just felt like, maybe
it happened two years ago.
I don't know, but.
- You felt that they were
taking advantage of you?
That you were entitled to it?
That there was some bullshit?
- Yeah, I felt a little bit like,
like wow they're my parents,
like they should be
hooking it up a little bit.
You know what I mean?
And yeah, it was crazy 'cause.
- What did your dad say?
- What did he say, he said.
- You're a grown ass man, now?
Stop, no more allowance?
- (laughs) Basically, basically.
- I liked your dad, at the
beginning of this video,
and I like him even more now.
- No, he's great, he's a great dad.
But there was a time when he was the like,
what we call him (speaks
in foreign language).
Which basically means, the bad guy.
- Of course.
- He was the bad guy
at one point because, you know.
With my mom it was all fun and whatever.
- Yeah, they divided and conquered.
They were good cop,
bad cop, that's common.
- Yep, yep.
But now, man, I respect him so much
because I started watching your content
and started realizing that I was entitled.
And I was like, what the heck?
'Cause it wasn't only the allowance thing
but several other little stuff.
And it started to liberate me.
But now I'm at the point
where I'm trying to work for him.
'Cause, you know, school got
shut down and all that stuff.
And also, my schedule's pretty loose
because I'm a senior in high school.
And so, I go to school for
like the first half of the day
and then I'll go work
for him the second half,
from like 12 to four.
- Love that, what does he do?
- We are an electrical company,
so he's an electrician.
Been an electrician for 28 years.
- Love it.
- And so,
that's what I'm going into.
But anyways, to get to
the actual question.
I'm starting to work consistently
like a 20 hour work week,
soon to be 40 after I graduate.
And sometimes I find
myself, during the week,
like there's days where I love it
and I having a good time with whatever.
And there's days that I won't, right?
And kind of feel like I'd rather stay home
and play on my drum set,
because that's something that I realize
I kind of like to do.
- But you have time to do that.
You're only working 20 hours.
- Man, this is why I wanna talk to you.
Beause I was like man, I just don't know.
I'm like, you talk about diving
into your passions and stuff.
But I'm like, I wanna also provide
and support for a future family.
- Yep.
- But then, it's like you say,
that not everyone's life
is gonna be like yours.
And that we can have the
work/life balance if we want it.
- Couple things.
So first of all, back to like
when I think about ingredients.
Like you have so many good ingredients.
Like I love your
perspective already at 18.
I like the thoughtfulness.
I love that you're over
the hump on entitlement.
I'm obsessed with the
admiration and respect
you have towards your parents.
You remind me a lot of me at 18 right now
because I just had a lot of that.
I think the one thing
that I was able to do
was I worked a lot more
than you did at this age.
And still thought I did have time to look
at my baseball cards, play Genesis.
Like I think that my work ethic
might have been more on point
than yours is, to be frank.
- Yeah, no, 100%.
- We're talking about 20 hours of work
and in that 20 hours, you're like,
damn I wish I was on my drum set.
I'm like, mother fucker.
You can be on your drum set
and work these 20 hours.
And even when you said,
soon to be 40 hours,
I laughed in my head, on some real shit.
'Cause I'm like, wait a minute, 40?
Like 40's different.
I was 85, 90, like real
fucking hours, and still--
- Yeah.
- So if you're gonna work 40,
you have a ton of fucking time
to fucking bang on your fucking drums,
you know, and try side hustles,
and hang out with friends,
and live your life, 40's nothing.
- Mhmm.
- It's nothing.
And what I mean be that
is you're in a great spot.
Because you have this like,
if you're talking, at 18,
about future family
you've got that immigrant
practicality shit in
your soul, which I love.
Like.
- What did you say I had?
- You have that immigrant
practicality already in your,
you're 18 years old.
Most 18 year olds don't think
about providing for a future family.
So I'm glad that you're
in that practical place.
But, bro, on some real shit, 40's nothing.
Like 40's nothing.
Like I don't even know
how to explain it to you.
Like I feel like you have an ability
to have some grit, and eat
some crow, and pay your dues.
- Yeah.
- I've got good news for you,
if it's really 40, you got off easy.
Family business, second generation?
Like that shit usually
looks more like 67, 82, 100.
Like if you're at 40,
you have tons of time
between 18 and 30 to put
into your side hustle
and starting a YouTube
channel around drums,
to hang out, to like, I mean, fucking 40.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You fucking hit the lottery if it's 40.
- Man.
- 40?
I use to work 40 in three days.
My Thursday, Friday, and
Saturday of every summer day,
since I was 14, was 40.
Seven to eight p.m., 13 hours times three.
Like, fucking 40, you're fucking set.
I'm real happy for you because I think
you're gonna be able to check every box.
You're gonna be able to
help the family business,
help yourself make some money,
but you still have 100
fucking hours in a week
to fucking sleep, spend time with friends,
and do your side hustle, you're fortunate.
- Now here's what I don't want
to happen.
- Go ahead.
- It's like, right now, I feel
good and I have that drive.
But what do I do when
tomorrow I feel that like,
like man, that was great
with Gary yesterday,
and now we're back to
it, and it's like cool.
And then next week it
slowly progresses down.
- You're on a high, right
now, tomorrow you go hard.
But then, in two weeks
you're back to that place
with two hours into the
day of electrician--
- Exactly.
- You're like fuck, I wish, so listen,
this is what being a man,
and this is what being an
operator in life is about.
Learning how to get comfortable
with the uncomfortable is the requirement.
You know what I mean, brother?
- Yeah, learning to get comfortable
with the uncomfortable, you said.
- That's right.
Learning to, like, when you're
in that zone at 11 a.m.,
you know, on July 19th, when you're like,
fuck man, I wish I was home playing drums
or I wish I was with my
boy Salvatore right now.
Like learning to get over that
hump is very required, right?
You know, we are so lucky.
We're so lucky that a
lot of people don't wanna
get a relationship with
being uncomfortable.
They just want everything
to be as awesome as,
like it's such macro entitlement,
as if everyone's life should
always be awesome at all times.
Don't create this narrative in your mind
of blaming your mom that
everything has to be happy
is why you're incapable.
- Yeah.
- That's not your mom trying to make
positives out of negatives.
That's you are fucking
so lucky that you had
such great parents that provided for you,
that you are not in a
place yet where you're,
like you're starting
this incredible process
of getting out of that entitlement.
And I'm proud of you.
So now what you need to do,
it's kind of like working out.
It's like kind of that extra
10 pounds on the weight.
Like this summer, is the--
- Just get those reps.
- Get those reps, that's
exactly right, man.
I love that you--
- 100%, bro.
- Like every time you're
at 11:30 in the morning,
and somebody yells at you at the job,
and you're like, fuck man,
I could just be home playing Xbox.
Every time you do that, you go into,
my fucking parents immigrated to America.
When they were my age, they
were fucking scared shitless
of making it in America.
They didn't have a fucking pot to piss in.
And I'm sitting here complaining
about a fucking family business
that my dad created on his fucking back.
- Yep.
- Go to gratitude, go to gratitude.
- (sighs) Man, I just gotta train it, man.
Because the main thing that
was confusing me is I was like,
I don't know.
'Cause you talk about, you know,
if you don't like going or whatever,
then you shouldn't be doing it.
But the thing was that I
was liking it sometimes,
but not liking it other times.
So then I was like, what's the deal here?
But you just, man, you just
hit me with the unlock,
that's so real.
- Because what's funny
about that, it's like, look,
unhappiness is not
something people should do.
But to your point, and this
is why I love doing Q and A.
When I say, don't do
something that you don't love,
I don't mean don't do something
you don't love for an hour.
I mean, don't let that
be your 80-year career.
- Yeah, that's real.
- Like to me, I also say, eat shit.
And like I believe in eating shit.
Like we just talked
about it in detail here,
11:30, July 19th, you
know Miguel on the job
yells at you and says, ah
kid, you fucking idiot!
And you're like, aw, fuck.
You know like, you know?
- Yeah.
- Like that's the moment
you take a step back
and you think about this conversation,
and you're like, right,
when my dad was my age.
When your dad was 18, you're 18 or 17?
- I'm 18, I'm 18.
- When your dad was 18,
tell me exactly what he
was doing if you know.
- He was hustling.
He was installing like video
game machines in Mexican,
what's it called?
Not really bars, but more just like
kind of convenience stores.
He would go into,
I tell you this story real quick.
He would go into the
store and tell the owners,
he'd be like, "Hey, you mind if I install
"these things for you?"
And they'd be like, "No, I don't want any
"little toys or anything."
And then he'd be like, "Here,
"let me leave them here for a day.
"And then I'll come back
tomorrow and pick them up.
"And if you still don't want them."
Basically, he would leave them there.
A bunch of kids would come play on them
and buy stuff from the store.
And then the store owners would be like,
"Yeah, okay I want them."
- Oh shit.
Bro, your dad was grinding.
- Mhmm.
- I'm sure your dad didn't love installing
fucking video games and fucking cranes.
You know, but bro, you have
your whole life in front of you.
You absolutely need to
build a relationship,
almost everybody under 30 in America,
almost everybody needs to find
a relationship with adversity
and getting comfortable with eating shit.
And I think it's gonna be a great summer
for you to like learn that.
And, bro, that 40 thing is huge to me.
Bro, I can't explain to you
how lucky I think you are.
40?
You have the whole
fucking rest of the week.
- 100%.
- If it's really 40, is
it gonna be really 40?
Which is great.
- Yeah, he said 40 to 50.
He said 40 to 50 if you wanted
to, you know what I'm saying?
- Bro, listen man, let
me tell you something.
I thought I was the hardest
working person, I knew,
when I was 28 years old
running Wine Library,
I fucking worked all day.
You know, eight a.m. to
fucking eight p.m. every day.
That was soft compared
to who I am now at 44.
I go harder, stronger, smarter.
This is about fucking reps
and gaining muscles, right?
You've got, you're a stocky dude.
I'm looking at you right now.
You know that if you worked
out like a fucking maniac
for a year, ate right, and
fucking lifted weights,
you'd be a fucking monster
'cause you got that build.
That's what I had mentally.
I had that fucking build mentally
but it was the fucking reps from 28,
that made me fucking
completely unstoppable.
Look at this like you're
going into training.
You're going into training 40 hours a day
to fucking put calluses
on your fucking hands.
Put fucking create thickness to your skin,
to your fucking dome.
You're creating, you understand?
This is you going into training.
- Yeah.
- You need to be like Rocky
in fucking "Rocky IV."
This is about going in the snow.
Like going into this like,
holy shit, I'm so lucky
that I get to go into training.
I'm gonna get paid to fucking train
how to be a fucking mental
assassin for the rest of my life.
You're lucky.
- Yeah.
That's so real, man.
- Yeah, bro, and you get
to do it with your dad?
You know how fucking lucky,
you're so fucking lucky.
Most people that are watching right now
have to do it for a boss they don't know.
The greatest thing that ever happened
to me is the memories of being
in the fucking trenches with my dad.
You know?
Like, you know, it's crazy
that I get to have those memories.
One day my dad's gonna be gone
and I'm gonna be so happy
about those hours I put in,
those war stories, you understand?
- Yeah.
And I'm crying because I'm happy.
I was on the fence and
I didn't wanna leave.
Because I liked the electrical
but I didn't wanna leave
to try to get a job in drumming, right?
Because I was like, I like both,
I like working with my dad.
And so this was really the unlock for me,
and that's why I'm feeling it, man.
- 40 hours a week, you can start
a drumming YouTube channel.
You could fucking work
at a drumming company,
you can work at a
drumming company at night.
You got 40 hours like thick.
- Yeah, you can go get gigs, yep.
- You could fucking,
you have so much time.
And you're gonna gain a strength.
You're gonna gain a strength.
- Yeah, man, that's so real,
of like, just being good
at being uncomfortable.
And being like, hey, you know,
this is kind of boring but
I'm gonna get through it,
because my family built this.
And, you know, I'm so grateful
for the opportunity to even have that.
Because a lot of people my
age, coming out of high school,
don't know what they wanna do.
- Right.
- Don't have a job.
- That's right, and you're
gonna learn a skill.
You're gonna learn how to
interact with grown ass men.
You're gonna learn how to interact
with customers that are upset.
You're gonna watch your
dad go through adversity,
you're gonna learn.
You're getting an education,
and you're training,
and you're gonna get paid?
You should be paying your dad!
- Yeah, 100%.
- That's how I looked at it, man.
I've been so grateful that I decided
that when I was, I realized
at 22 that I had it,
and I decided, you know what?
Instead of go and build
something for myself,
'cause I could.
I knew the internet, I knew the hustle.
I fucking knew it, I was making
$5oo, $1,000, when I was 13.
I was 22, I was a grown ass man.
I didn't need to go into
my dad's business for me,
I needed to go into my dad's
business for me, emotionally,
because I wanted to give
back because I knew I could.
And I knew I was gonna
learn a lot of stuff.
And I was gonna enjoy it.
And I was gonna enjoy the memories.
And I was gonna put my dad on.
And it's the best 12 years of my career.
Did it feel great to be 34
and not own anything of
a business you built?
You know, no.
Did it feel great to
not have a lot of money?
Because, in a family business,
you really never pay yourself that much.
You know, if I was an
executive of the business,
from three to 60 million,
I would've been paid a million a year.
But, no.
But those memories with my dad.
And giving back to my parents,
who came to this country with nothing,
and built the foundation that I stand on.
That's something I'll never regret.
And you're gonna have that opportunity.
And if I fucking only did 40 hours a week,
I would've probably
started a baseball card,
"Starting Lineups," Ebay flipping
business on the side too.
And gotten double, you know, like happy.
So like, you really have it good, bro.
- Mhmm.
And it's so crazy that you say that,
because of the fact that like, literally,
only like a week and a half ago,
I told my mom, and I just talked with her.
I was like, man, I'm so
grateful for you guys.
Because I just felt this gratitude wave
of like, man, I'm so grateful,
but I just didn't know how to apply it
to the work thing because I was confused.
I'm like, whether or not.
But man, it's all about
the perspective of like,
man when I'm older, I'm gonna
be able to look back and say,
I got to work with my dad.
I got to do the 40 hours, like you said.
And I can still do my
other stuff, you know.
- Bro, you could go 80
hours, for seven years,
and fucking be 25 and young as fuck.
I'd rip both my arms
off right now to be 25.
You can go 90 hours a week, do no drums,
and bounce out of there
as a fucking child.
Still a child.
- Mhmm.
- You have everything.
You have gratitude, and good perspective,
and maturity at 18.
And you have your whole
life in front of you.
You got 100 more years of life.
You're gonna live for 100 more years, bro.
I'm for real shit.
You're a part of that lucky generation.
You're gonna live to 118, mother fucker.
- No, I believe that.
- Yes.
- I can see that, I can see it.
At least 100.
- 118, you're gonna live 100 more!
Listen to me, you will
never, ever, ever regret
working 40 to 50 hours
a week with your dad
for the next prolonged period
of time, I promise you that.
I'm rarely that definitive,
but I've spent enough
time with you right now
to know that to be true.
You've got too much of
that soul and gratitude
towards your parents.
Any kid who's watching, right now,
who is grateful and loves their parents
for what they did for them,
should go into the family business.
Because even if it's a disaster,
you'll always be happy that
you paid back, a little bit,
to the thing that put you on.
(mellow instrumental music)